you may have heard people say there's no
standard day
in the seal teams yeah that's absolutely
true you don't have hey this is just a
normal day but but what i think this
highlights is there's just no kind of
standard career there's so many
different directions things can go
that
you're just gonna have a different
experience and what's cool is you can
have some control over that experience
you have you get you you have the
capability of adjusting i mean you look
at
gif and i
very you know came in at the same time
we're in the same buzz class we kind of
like the same
same we're on the same path and yet you
know he's speaking vietnamese we we both
became radio men but he speak in
vietnamese just all these different
things happen he ends up like doing the
the the advanced special operation stuff
just it's just different things happen
and you just get different experiences
so it's that to me
is a benefit to
joining the military
is and
i can only really say this with 100
certainty about the seal teams because
that's where i spent my time
but
most of the military everyone i talked
to it's the same thing you have it's
like a choose your own adventure book
the chances that somebody else chooses
the same adventure as you is very small
yeah so
awesome to talk to chris
and and hear
and hear his
because because
he's a friend this is the other that's
crazy thing about the sale teams like
your friends come and go
and you may not see a guy for
like when i saw him downstairs i don't
think i've seen him for
probably
15 years
15 years we we
and we he he hit me up like god is my
number whatever and he's like hey hey
john i'm in town like oh cool you want
to come hang out you want to be on the
podcast you'd be oh yeah i'd be awesome
i let's do it all the time so just but
no no like well how have you been no
because it's a shared you have this
shared common background yeah and then
with that shared common background your
friends you're like cool
i have friends i don't talk to if i saw
them tomorrow be like hey you know uh no
factor like no factor that's the knowing
may i there's no hey you didn't call me
no one expects you to call me don't
expect me to call you i'm not calling
you you're not gonna call me cool but if
you need something call me call me you
don't have to call me you don't say prep
call me you don't have to keep you have
to send me birthday cards whatever
um you need me cool i'll show up or you
want to you got you you're in town give
me a shout we'll go roll we'll see
what's up
you
it does go to show too how like it's
almost like if you put it into
perspective where you have people with
such different backgrounds and then they
kind of can converge on this
navy seal journey they get washed up and
filtered out and then they get kind of
spit out into their you know common
interest for sure and common goals but
in such different ways like if you talk
to you know how you say like navy seals
don't have a stereotype or they you
think they have a stereotype i think
they do what they don't but they don't
yeah this is like a really good example
because a man you know i'm talking to
him he's like a
super nice kind of introverted person
and then now talk to you you're like no
way that they were like
pods in the team like it doesn't
make sense and have the exact difference
and have the exact same job yeah hung
out and did stuff together yeah
and then so
like i'm trying to imagine you know like
every time everyone talks like when they
tell their story i always try to kind of
put myself like i wonder how they were
you know like what they look like i see
them in front of me now but what did
they look like the young version you
know what gif looked like
he looked exactly like that he looked
exactly the same just
darker hair probably he had darker hair
but he looked the same you know it's
almost the same build
i mean i
i'm i'm bigger than i would like when we
went through buds when we started buzz i
was 174 you know i'm 230 right now he
probably weighs somewhere in the
neighborhood well
i don't know what he weighed in buds but
he looks about the same yeah you know
and sure does he have a couple more
wrinkles whatever
we all do
but looks about the same yeah so you
imagine him like just functioning you
know i can't imagine him yelling at
nobody to me is he's just like this
super friendly person but i'm sure he
was like getting after it the way
everyone else was it's weird that
contrast is really weird it's fun
interesting it is uh good stuff man good
stuff oh it's
always good to talk to your old friends
and see where they're